金ちゃんに対するバット貼っちゃっぱ皆さんビデオ壁だとか金を使ったわかります
でしょうか
今撮ってるこれも美女カメラなんですけどもあの長年 youtube 行って来て
思ったんですけどもビジョンカメラとカメラって絶対液晶が付いてるんですよ
これところまさにそうですご覧くださいご理由はカメラには絶対行き症っていうのが
ついて
そのカメラいて何を撮っているのかというのもこのモニターもいいすごく
瞭然なわけなんですよそこではだ
ジュニーターナーの僕メッツカメラ持ってたんですよ水を使っているやつこれ問屋が
引くくらい出てくるパッチと聞かないでねコレット
このビデオカメラとなんか最近発売7ユーチューバーのカメラと
迎え使ってたキヤノンの一眼とちょっと昔使ってたなんか良さげなビデオカメラとへ
[ __ ]ばから米映画とかと竜のカメラといや自分気持ちはれるのはそんなプロの
カメラマンで比べたら全然ですけども
口みたいななんか総合ない動画撮るためだけにこんなにカメラさんの釣っ結構やばいと
思うんですよねらー今日こんなたくさん買ったことが良い海の日記書きました
どうなるか分からないんですけども加盟卵を撮るカメラを取るか[ __ ]を撮るカメラを
撮るカメラを撮るカメラを撮るカメラを取る壁なお
とってみたらどうなるのかやってみようと思います
俺もよくわかんないんですよその間で絶対液晶といけないんでこれ全米一ついてるん
ですよ
れきしょここじゃれ後全米一章ついてるんですけども cad などが映画の手法で
映像があってそれが実はテレビの中でしたみたいなやつあるじゃない加工
うーん
わかります伝わるさんないとマジでやばいことするんやっちゃう変態とドラム3でのや
捨てた奴が実は主人公見たチビの中でしたという主人公たちも2テレビの中ででした
っていうやつを見てる主人公出せばてるん奴でしょっていうのはこんな平和すごい
たくさん素敵な映像を撮れると思って本当にか現実か分からないような不思議な空間
英語訳をお届けしたいと思いますちょっとできる
若菜家だってないぞ
うわぁこうやって見ると黒光りしてるなぁ相手にで今回は全然あるカメラ方です
よろしくお願いしますよろしく
願いしまーす
そして三間堂をしっかり準備させていただきました集まれ三脚の森まぁこんなやれば
十分じゃないでしょうか
ガンナーへ
いっ
うっ
b
いきました本当は外で撮りたかったんですけどもな汁で a に雨が止まらないんで
いえなかでありますそのためにカメラを置いていきましょう
最後これに続きようにカメラを切ります ok
ポイントどうなんだこれ映像アンなくなったらやりたいとかどう
を受けておりました
[音楽]
pr
すごいわいやすごいは
配置場なんか準備的な授業できたんですけども
統計がすごいいらっしゃるツーパンチパッっ
光景がすごすぎで移動すればまだなんか誰ですご覧ください1年まとめたな始まり
bo カーラー入札 dgh 5 ex ファイン商品の美女カーラーソニーの bd
カラーユーチューバーカメラいやーすごい横並びまでは最後にこのカメラもう組んで
もう1台多いんですけどってきましたじゃあ正著
どういう映像になるかって画素のカメラでおりが映ってたら本当にすごいと思います
たぶん2ないと思うけど果たして
カメラ越しのカメラ越しのカメラボスの食べることのため星のカメラがそのカメラます
のカメラ越しのカメラはどうなっているのかさっそくとってみようと思いますですかー
[音楽]
おっ
pr
tee
ん
はいというわけで
どうですか唯一 is に三枝
な感じ9人がカメラ館で撮ってまあ大丈夫俺一番後ろの壁だからそむ食ってるかどうか
なんですよ見えましたーーー
初めて長栄寺みますかー
あっ長文です
[音楽]
blr